there is a classic science experiment that you have probably tried where you mix baking soda and vinegar to make a small volcanic eruption
but I think we can make it a little
better so for this video i teamed up
with lenovo so i can use their new yoga
book to help me super size this
experiment and make it a little bit
cooler a cool feature of the yoga book
is we can slap a piece of paper over the
halo keyboard and now as we sketch out
our plans it instantly digitizes the
design in real-time a typical science
fair volcanoes probably somewhere
between 6 to 14 inches tall but we're
going to make our volcano 14 feet tall
here's how we're going to engineer it
inside the volcano we're going to have
three steel discs we're gonna have a
12-foot 8-foot and forefoot steel ring
and we're gonna build some two by four
wraps off of that so that we can step up
and step down safely
once we've got those in place we're
going to use paperback chicken wire to
cover the volcano and then spray it with
insulating foam we're going to cover the
whole thing and stucco paint it and then
use spray adhesive to stick real moss
around the base and make it look as
authentic as possible
now that we got the volcano built let's
work on making the rocket fuel and I
thought for our epic volcano rather than
using baking soda and vinegar we can
make it a little more explosive by using
the same composition I used in my
pyrotechnic by the two main ingredients
of my pyrotechnics I were just sugar and
potassium nitrate mixed together in a
60-40 ratio the reason this reaction
works is because the sugar acts as the
fuel to keep the reaction going to buy
products of this reaction are potassium
carbonate which is the black ash that
falls down from the sky and we also get
carbon dioxide water and nitrogen gas my
pyrotechnic pi used about 1 pound of
this composition which was enough to
fill about an 8 inch pie crust imagine
something like this but a hundred times
bigger
you know guys this thing turned out
really really good it is 14 feet tall
and it's not made out of paper mache we
built this thing out of steel and stucco
and packed full of rocket fuel
we also put three mortars in their
little shoot off sparks 20 feet high and
like the whole thing to remote igniters
with the press of a button on our halo
keyboard the whole thing will go off in
all its glory
the water in order to really well that
is what 35 pounds of rocket fuel looks
like shoved into a giant science
experiment
I mean if you were here you would have
felt black ash raining down from the sky
just like the real volcanic eruption
this is so freaking cool i've never seen
anything like this done before
thanks for joining me for this
experiment i'll be looking for you in
the next one
dr. Ben we've even got freakin lava I
mean look at this stuff that is not
tomato sauce